We've been friends
since the first semester.
And from the first semester,
you're bombarded with Gehry
and you start to get into
the internet and Art Daily.
And you see a ton of things
that are really colorful
with interesting
or whimsical shapes.
But in some way,
I think we were always curious
and wanted to look for
other kinds of architecture.
And we became interested
in other types of architects.
I think that if there's a building
and the outside of it
doesn't catch your eye
when you pass it on the street,
then, you go in and discover
there's another universe inside
I think this is an important
concept when it comes to
what we want
or try to accomplish
each time we design a building.
So, this site...
a site with lots of strength
like this patio
with its walls
that are 4.8 meters high
and in such a cool color,
well, not cool, but...
- Neutral.
- Really neutral and gray.
It was impossible to ignore
and it was really important
for us to adapt
the irregular shape
of this patio and its walls.
To use the walls as a structure.
For this process,
the concrete was poured in molds,
and the holes remained
completely hollow
and that's something we,
don't see often in Mexico.
For me, this really
caught my attention...
how this sort of “scar”
has been made in the wall.
Andrés said,
“We have to use these holes.”
So, in order to make a cover
using the holes...
the easiest way was with threads.
It's only a little taut.
We had the idea of mist
from the beginning,
even before
we started with the ropes,
when we started to think about
creating a refreshing atmosphere.
We decided to use the gallery
that no one uses
to create the mist there
and make the experience more dense,
an atmosphere.
Did you take the nozzles out?
Good, good, good.
I hope it works.
How things work
is important.
You can see how they're made.
I think there were three models
in two weeks before making
the final model.
Making a model
helps you realize how complicated
or easy it will be
when you actually build it.
How do you make an embankment
that will hold,
but is also fixed to the ground
and also holds sand
and well, you have to do it.
You have to try, like weaving,
and say, we're going to weave.
And there were a thousand problems.
We have a bit –
a piece of wood inside the hole.
I don't know how,
but we will remove it.
We have the opportunity now
to build the installation
with our own hands.
We're having fun.
I would love it
if everything in life were like this,
if you were always involved
in all of the processes,
and well,
it never stops being a game.
Truly, for us, architecture
is always a game.
We want to show you the simplicity
of how things are made,
so you have no doubts.
Actually, architecture should
give you answers
about how to live in the world.